Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and I know it’s
only Friday but I’m posting a new Game of
Thrones video just because I’m going to
be doing more Walking Dead on Sundays.
So I think Thursdays or Fridays will be my
new Game of Thrones Bonus video day.
More details on schedule updates at the end
of the video.
This is just going to be a fun TAG Game I
found.
So I’ll tag a couple of you guys when I’m
done.
Starting with Question 1: Favorite One-Off
Episode From any Season?
Just picking one episode I’d say Red Wedding,
I think it still beats the Purple Wedding
along with Blackwater in terms of moments
of shock and awe.
At the time it aired, I knew what the story
was, I’d read Book 3, but it had been so
long I wasn’t really thinking about it that
much.
And I had only just started making videos.
So I wasn’t quite as dialed in to the day
to day spoilers and news of the show.
So even right up to the episode I wasn’t
really thinking Red Wedding.
They even titled it Rains of Castamere, so
unless you were really thinking hard about
it.
You wouldn’t have been thinking everyone
is going to die.
But the way the whole episode came together
in terms of pacing, the set design and oh
god the music.
It was, in my mind, the most perfect moment
of television that year.
Of any show or any big event.
By the time Season 4 rolled around, I was
so dialed into the behind the scenes stuff
that there were very few surprises.
The White Walker scene in Episode 4 was really
the only big big surprise.
Question 2: Favorite Villain?
Technically there are no villains, but right
now definitely the Mountain.
The books give you some background as to possible
reasons he might be such a mean person, but
on the show, they very clearly paint him as
a monster.
Squishing a beloved character’s head like
a grape will rocket you to the top of the
villain list.
Question 3: Least Favorite Main Character?
I’d say Shae, she wasn’t a main character
in the books and there was a reason for that.
The show tried to turn her into something
more but I felt like Peter Dinklage could
have just talked to himself and it would have
been more enjoyable.
I think part of the reason they jumped her
up from guest cast to main cast was because
they gave so much more screen time to Tyrion
and they needed to paint him as sympathetic.
I don’t think they needed all the Shae scenes
to do that.
Peter Dinklage is amazing all by himself.
But either way, that little issue cleared
itself up as of the finale.
Question 4: Favorite Sidekick?
This is easy, always Podrick.
He’s also a character that’s gotten more
time on the show that he didn’t get in the
books.
I’m totally loving the Brienne Podrick scenes
so far.
I like them together more as a pair than when
Podrick was with Tyrion.
They just work better together.
Both characters want nothing more than to
become knights.
Just to be clear though, I don’t ship them
or anything like that.
He’s merely there for comedic value.
That’s why we didn’t really see him during
the big fight with the hound.
Question 5: Character You Love To Hate?
The one person I really ENJOY hating is Ramsay
Bolton.
He’s written that way but the actor who
plays him takes it to this crazy place where
you do have fun wanting him to die horribly.
Before we met him it would have be Joffrey
of course, but after a while hating joffrey
became less of a self-aware fun thing to do
and more of a please make him go away now,
kind of thing.
I feel like we get just the right amount of
Ramsay, I think that was part of my problem
with Joffrey after a while.
If he’s being forced down your throats by
the camera it’s a lot harder to enjoy him.
All things in moderation, even torturing Theon.
Question 6: Favorite Friendship?
My favorite one that’s not an implied romance
is Jon and Samwell.
I’m sure there’s a tumblr ship out there.
But they feel like they have a very familiar
camraderie and they both completely understand
what their relationship is all about.
Help each other survive.
Brienne and Jaime would normally be my answer,
but their relationship isn’t as much about
friendship as it is romance.
So I’m just focusing on true friends.
Although that being said, you could say the
Starks and their direwolves.
So many of them have been separated though.
So Jonwell or Direwolves.
Question 7: Friendship that never felt Real
to You?
Any friendship Littefinger was ever a part
of.
He is the one person I feel like has no friends.
I really think inside him somewhere, he understands
that everyone is just a piece on a gameboard
for him to move around.
The books spell out his feelings for Catelyn
a little more specifically.
I do believe that he loved her, but where
he is in the story right now, he’s completely
twisted that.
If not for Ramsay Bolton, he would probably
be one of the most evil people on the show.
Just for the emotional crimes he commits,
to say nothing of the actual crimes he commits.
If he had his way, everything would just crumble
to dust and he’d laugh because everyone’s
toys would be broken.
Question 8: Favorite Wise-Guy/Joke Teller?
Easily Tyrion, Bronn tells a lot of jokes,
but Tyrion has this nervous laugh that actually
makes him funnier.
Even when he’s not trying to be funny.
It’s like, “I’m not laughing because
I think my own jokes are funny.”
“I’m laughing because I’m nervous someone
will kill me at any moment.”
Question 9: Least Favorite Villain?
Littlefinger, he’s clearly a villain, even
if he’s usually not the most vicious one
like the Mountain.
I think I’d have more fun with the character
if Aiden Gillen didn’t do the batman voice
all the time.
I get it, Littlefinger is oily in a mustache
twirling kind of way.
But he could still speak in normal voice and
it would be just as creepy.
This is just a show thing, in the books, I
control the way he sounds just using my imagination.
The show takes that choice away from you.
Question 10: Least Favorite Season Long Storyline?
I hate to say it but Bran did kind of get
dropped.
He has a remarkable storyline, but because
it didn’t involve face squashing or naked
whores they show didn’t really do much with
it.
Bran’s journey adds this nice mystical dimension
to song of ice and fire that gives you a different
perspective than what you get from Melisandre.
Hopefully Season 5 will bring that out a little.
I saw that the girl who played the child of
the forest was listed as being in Episode
1 of Season 5, so presumably they’ll follow
up on what happened in the finale.
Question 11: Talk about a character with a
bad story or character arc?
I’m a pretty loyal Martin fan, so technically
I don’t think there are any bad character
arcs.
This video is mostly show related, so if I
had to pick I’d say Shae.
The way her character ended made her seem
like such a piece of trash.
If she was supposed to be a big main character,
Martin would have written her to be a little
more aware of Tyrion’s reasons for pushing
her away.
She was supposed to be clever, but if she
was clever why wouldn’t she just wait things
out for a few years overseas till Tyrion could
bring her back.
A Song of Ice and Fire is all about the LONG
con, it’s not a short term game.
Question 12: Character that pisses you off
no matter how much you try to like them?
Samwell definitely.
He’s written that way though.
He’s like the Lisa Simpson of the story.
He’ll probably gain all the knowledge they
need to defeat the white walkers, but because
he’s such a fool.
No one will listen to him.
Jon listens to him, but that only goes so
far.
Jon can’t do everything by himself.
The other brothers of the Night’s Watch
also have to have faith in Samwell and I don’t
think they take him seriously yet.
I’m really interested to see how closely
Samwell’s arc stays to the books in season
5.
Question 13: Plot Device That Gets Used To
Much?
Definitely using whorehouse sex scenes to
convey exposition.
People started calling it sexposition, Game
of Thrones was the show that started that
back in Season 1 or 2 I think.
They haven’t done it as much since Littlefinger
left his whorehouse at King’s Landing, but
every new episode I always wonder when the
big explainer scene is coming and who’s
going to be having the sex while they explain
something.
That would make a great EDU Sex ed youtube
channel.
Sexpositions.
I’ll book mark that for later.
Question 14: Favorite Character Death Scene?
Definitely Oberyn Martell, when Joffrey Died
all I could think was thank god it’s finally
over.
Oberyn’s character arc was so much more
interesting and it didn’t drag on for too
many seasons.
It also helped that it came after one of the
most exquisite fight scenes the show has ever
done.
and last one, Question 15: Abandoned or Unanswered
Plot Line That will always Bug You?
Until we hear otherwise, this is always going
to be Gendry.
As of now he’s still rowing his way from
Dragonstone to King’s Landing.
There are any number of directions they can
take the character.
I know a lot of you want him to meet up with
Arya again.
I won’t say what happens in the books, but
if you have read please use spoiler tags in
terms of what’s going on with her in season
5.
Of all the characters in season 5, I feel
like Arya’s will be one of the arcs that
stays closer to the books.
Book 4 specifically if you guys want to read
ahead.
So I have to tag a few people, I’ll tag
KaosDevice, DrakeVagabond, Rag Princess Sews
and simply maya beauty.
It’s okay if you guys can’t make videos,
just do a tumblr post and tweet the link out
with my name in it so it shows up in my mentions
on twitter.
I’m also creating a poll for our first re-watch
episode, once we find an episode and a time
everyone can watch it, we’ll give it a try.
Links for everything in the description.
You can click here to learn more about some
of
the season 5 characters and click here to
learn about my fall schedule and all the shows
and movies and stuff I’m doing videos for.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!